[Music]
hello boys and girls ladies and germs
this is tim ferriss welcome to another
episode of the tim ferriss show i'm
speaking quickly because we're going to
cover a lot of ground
we have ramit seti
ramith seti if you want to get it right
but that's confusing because it's
r-a-m-i-t
space last name s-e-t-h-i you can find
him on twitter and instagram
at ramit r-a-m-i-t he's author of the
new york times bestseller i will teach
you to be rich
has helped tens of millions of people
live a rich life with their monies
careers and businesses and psychology he
hosts more than a million readers on his
site i will teach you to be rich dot com
newsletter and social media his new
podcast i will teach you to be rich by
bernie sethi reveals real stories about
love and money from behind closed doors
you can find him on instagram remate on
twitter at ramit
and you can find podcast episodes at
iwt.com forward slash podcast
for meet you sexy son of a [ __ ] welcome
back to the podcast
oh man it's good to be here and i must
say we were
talking about this while we were doing a
little bit of pre-game but the
expectations are gonna be very high
you have been on the podcast several
times some of your episodes are the most
downloaded of all time
across 600 or so episodes now
so we will need to get to a lot of
tactical
practical and we're going to discuss a
lot of i think
sensitive topics we're going to get into
some juicy territory for folks talking
about couples
money all things in betwixt and in
between
and or maybe it's is it betwixt in
between i can't remember i'm trying to
get too old-timey
but let's just jump right into it
because you and i have had many
conversations
offline we've had many conversations
publicly and there's a lot more
to explore so as a starter what are some
of the most
memorable money conversations that you
have had
in the last few years because it's been
a bit since we had
our last conversation on the podcast so
a lot has transpired
the last time we talked we talked about
prenups
and what that was like walking in and i
remember giving you a call and
i said you know hey we could talk about
this on your podcast and you said wait
you'll actually share the details i say
yeah
and that was very juicy because nobody
talks about this kind of stuff
publicly right so after
getting married and going through that
process with my wife
i thought okay great done deal you know
kind of
wiping my hands together oh we're all
good
and then i started speaking to other
couples about their money
and you know i remember speaking to
a number of couples the first one that i
spoke to was
a couple where one person had over 500
000 of debt he was a vet by the way
interestingly the people who i speak to
who are in the most
severe debt are veterinarians it's very
interesting
and he was very nonchalant about it no
big deal like we'll find a way
no problem his wife felt totally
constrained and constricted
there's nothing they could do they were
putting off moving
because there was this huge looming
ghost in the middle of their
relationship
i got interested and i started speaking
to more and more couples
and i remember talking to another couple
where there was a young woman and she
had paid off something like 50 000
of debt which was very impressive but
whenever her
husband said let's go on a trip the
first
thing she would say is oh we can't do
that
we can't do that because my debt and so
i said to her
when you finally pay off your debt do
you think you're going to magically
change
the way you think about money and she
was silent
and she said yeah with a question mark
at the end
yeah which means no people
tend to have this it's a false belief
that
one day when they pay off their debt or
one day when they make a certain amount
of money they're going to magically
change the way they think and act about
money
and the fact of the matter is that
doesn't happen
and so that is why i got interested in
speaking to couples
and they let me in to their
conversations their private
conversations about love and money
can i just share a quick personal side
note and i'm not drunk i'm not over
caffeinated people if you're wondering
why i'm such a loose cannon already
today
but i thought you would appreciate this
because we've had a lot of conversations
like this
so i'm in a house right now with a
brand new washer and dryer but a few
weeks ago
i was i was agonizing over whether or
not to get a washer dryer because i'd
been doing wash and fold and paying
kind of by the load to get clothing
washed and folded it was it was pretty
inconvenient
and i was talking to someone about it
and i'm spending a lot of time
considering whether i should continue
using washer
and fold or getting a washer dryer and
i i mentioned the cost of the washer
dryer
and so on and so forth and i said you
know for that
i could do this number of wash and fold
sessions and that i expect would take x
number of weeks or
months and really i'm only here for a
certain period of time
and at the end they were like tim i
think you can just spring for the washer
dryer
but the amount of time that i spent
like running this calculus and weighing
the pros and cons was a great
illustration of uh terrible
investment of resources and time well
it's deep in you
and i think you know when you when you
think back to four hour work week and
some of the
analyses you did right you can tell you
love the spreadsheet
and you love comparing certain things
it's in you
and for you know i think a lot of sort
of tech oriented guys
in particular it's in them it's not
painful to us to sit there and compare
things we'll do it forever
i'll give you an example from one of the
people i spoke to this one really blew
my mind
so he goes ramit i
love to get a good deal i said okay
i can already tell where this is going
by the way and it's not good but i said
okay he said whenever i
order groceries online i
hate the idea of overpaying i said
really
he said so i open up two tabs i have
whole foods on one side
and i have whatever competitor on the
other ramit you're not going to believe
it
sometimes they charge 15 for organic
groceries
but over here i can get it for seven
dollars i said
wow by the way what's your net worth tim
you want to guess
[Laughter]
you know i i i don't want to even hazard
a guess i'll tell you what was the
8 million dollars now
it's very easy for us to laugh okay and
even he laughed as i just sat there
silently
staring at him you know but
what what is revealed there is that it's
not a certain number that's going to
change the way
we feel about money and if you're
listening to this right now maybe you
have a partner maybe you've had a couple
arguments about money or you just don't
see eye to eye on certain things
the easiest way that we rationalize it
is to say
well if we just get that promotion or if
we just save this much then
everything will be perfect but my friend
who i spoke to
who has an eight million dollar net
worth listening to him you know
it's not about the dollar value it's not
and nothing will change that feeling
unless he
personally works on it along with his
partner
all right so i i want to plant a seed
we're going to come back
to specific questions i want to ask you
what
sort of the prying bar looks like what
tools you use
when talking to couples that you found
illuminating
and helpful right questions that people
then who are listening might use
before we get to that my question is and
we don't have to spend a ton of time on
it but
why did it take you so goddamn long to
start a podcast
um yeah all of my podcast friends
including you are like are you stupid
they keep telling me this you know you
should have done this 10 years ago
i'm just slow you know i'm just i don't
know i don't know what else to say i
have no good excuse really
i don't believe i don't buy that
[ __ ] excuse
me so you there has to be some calculus
involved here well i guess something
led to you doing the podcast yes okay so
i asked you a lot
over the course of many years i was like
hey i'm thinking about it and you had
some great advice for me you know record
this many episodes etc
the thing that i love about your podcast
is you
really love interviewing all these
different people
from across the spectrum i don't
my nightmare is waking up and talking to
a bunch of people who wrote some book
i'm like i don't really all right let's
cut this short i gotta go
but what i do love is talking to
ordinary people
about psychology and money
and in particular the difference between
what we claim we want to do
and what we actually do you know hey i
know i should be eating healthier but i
don't why not let's get into that no
judgment
but let's try to peel the onion and try
to figure that out
and part of that is just myself you know
i
i had a lot of things i claimed i wanted
to do but i didn't really
follow through and when i finally
figured out that i could just talk to
people and ask them about their money
and they would trust me enough to share
real numbers
then i started to be like wait a minute
this could actually work
and after trying it a couple times i
realized
i could do this for four hours a day
every day and i would
love it that's why i decided to try it
out
you also there are certain things that
you'd be willing to do four hours a day
that are utterly
puzzling and hilarious to me just for
people who are like
that sounds like a politician's answer i
don't
buy it i don't buy it ramit i will tell
you this is also someone
who has done very well in business and
in life that's
roommate who loves
to feed the trolls you will send me
extensive threads of just toying with
trolls from email
because tim when do you get a chance to
meet someone
who walks up to you in this case on
instagram and
the first thing they say is [ __ ] you
and i go are you having a bad hair day
let's discuss
what do you what kind of burrito do you
like and then the responses are just
truly unbelievable you know 50 of them
right off the bat
they go oh i didn't even know someone
actually reads this account
which leads to another question why on
earth would you write into the ether
if you didn't expect anyone to write
back i don't know do you not find that
fascinating i do find it interesting and
this is just to lend credibility to your
answer
you choose your sports in a unique way
just so everyone listening
let's make sure we we capture that he
just said ramit is credible because he
spends hours a day
interacting with trolls on instagram tim
i don't know if that's helping me out
here man
that was a bit of a journalist reframe
so what you're saying is by the way pro
tip to anyone who's ever interviewed if
someone says oh so i guess what you're
kind of saying is a b and c
do not just say yes quickly to that
because they will take that and they
will quote you as saying whatever they
just said
they are trying to write their piece in
advance by paraphrasing you
be very careful so those are your words
mr seti not mine however let's come to
the questions so what types of questions
what are some specific questions
you like to ask or that people can ask
each other
or in the context of a therapy session
that they might use
that you found useful first question i
always start with
is in the last 30 days can you think of
a specific situation where you were
not on the same page financially with
your partner
and this is a great question for a
couple of reasons number one
30 days limits you otherwise people
often feel like they have to give you
their whole life history
and i don't need their whole life
history truthfully i only need a little
bit
just to advance to the next question
that's number one
and then being on the same page is
pretty gentle you know some people get
in
fights and some people they just
disagree about you know who should pay
for
the check at dinner and so it doesn't
have to be this massive 10 out of 10
argument but i do want to hear where
they were not aligned
from there it just kind of flows because
people
instantly can remember something from
the last 30 days and they love
to talk about it then the next question
i ask as i get into it i'll ask him
what is your rich life now this is a
concept that i've been talking about for
about 15
20 years on my site and that is the idea
that
you don't have to cut back on lattes
life isn't about competing who can be
more frugal
you know there's more to life than
optimizing cell c3 of your spreadsheet
but i want to hear people talk about
what their rich life is
i had a young woman whose rich life was
i want to shop at whole foods without
counting the prices
of whatever i buy now okay that's fine
if you're just starting out maybe you're
in 25 000
of debt she was professionally extremely
successful
so with that i kind of push her i say
okay let's say you could do that
tomorrow
how much would your shopping cart cost
she said uh like a hundred i said push
it get something really nice
150. i said you know you make x
hundred thousand dollars a year let's
dream a little bigger and this
is a huge topic that unfolds because
again another interesting insight about
couples
most people have never thought about
what their rich life is
individually much less what their rich
life is
together so question about this woman so
if she's making hundreds
of thousands dollars per year in fact
maybe i'm missing something obvious but
she could very easily afford to spend
150
at whole foods so did she just feel as
though she could not or she wouldn't
allow herself to do that or did she feel
like she needed
tens of millions of dollars in order to
without
guilt spends 150 at whole foods
how did that conversation unfold
people's feelings
about how they are doing financially are
highly
uncorrelated with their actual financial
status i spoke to a couple uh on the
lower east side in manhattan
and they were living in a one-bedroom
and they were saving a lot of money
the uh their income was 330 000 a year
and i said to them how do you all feel
you're doing and they said
we don't know we have no idea are we
doing well are we doing horrible we
don't know
and that's one of the problems which is
no one talks about money
you have no idea how to benchmark
yourself particularly if you live in a
city like manhattan where
spending is different than living in
chicago for example
and so they had no idea and when you
take a couple look at some basic metrics
what's your savings rate what's your
expenses
you know what is your housing cost and i
said to them you guys are doing
really well you should give yourself a
pat on the back and they go
okay yeah yeah yeah so anyway we got
this question about our accounts i said
hold on a second
let's celebrate for just a second you've
done really well
and i think there's a lack of
celebration with couples
because there's just so much uncertainty
around it i would imagine there's a lot
of
positional economics also right in a
place like manhattan where it's like if
you have three friends who are doing
or appear to be doing substantially
better than you are
then you will evaluate yourself very
differently than
if you are in your peer group doing the
best
even if in absolute dollar amounts you
were making less in the latter
instance right i have to imagine that's
also a big part of it so if you
live in a place that is highly
competitive with many successful people
like manhattan your reference point
is going to make celebrating in some
respects more difficult
i think that's true and i think that
americans
love to compare themselves to their
neighbors i love it
well americans love to do a few things
that are completely irrational they love
to think that if they do certain things
it'll make them happy
and then they do the exact thing that
will make them unhappy
we love it and we can go into all this
but think about the typical
couple living in some suburban city
think about the conversations that are
happening about money regarding their
neighbors
well how did leah and john go on
vacation for the third time this year
you know maybe we should be going on
vacation for a third time this year
and it doesn't have to be living in
manhattan you can be living anywhere
what's going on there the answer is that
money is
opaque money is unclear
because you might have a different
savings goal than
i do and also there's a lot of
secret sources of where money comes from
oftentimes you'll find that parents are
funding certain things
oftentimes you'll find that people are
in debt oftentimes you'll find someone's
actually just
really wealthy and they make a lot more
money than you think they make
or they're really in debt and they have
the picture of financial health but
they're funding it
by sort of lighting their credit on fire
yeah
that's also possible let's come back to
rich life so when you ask someone about
their rich life
what their rich life looks like so you
gave us an example
of the disconnect right between
someone's
sort of objective financial status and
then the whole foods
shopping what would be your answer okay
just so we can have an idea of models of
what
a more fleshed out answer might look
like i would say that
i want to travel for six to eight weeks
six weeks consecutively at the end of
the year when i fly i wanna fly in this
exact
airline seat and when i travel i wanna
stay at
these three different hotels and i wanna
bring
one or more family members with me when
i travel
and cost is not the first second or
third
issue when i take these trips so that's
an example
another example would be i don't want to
start working until 10 a.m every day
that could be an example and and just so
everybody knows i
finally boiled these down into what i
call ramit's money rules
so it's almost like a personal value
statement i'll give you a couple of them
some of them are kind of boring and some
of them are super permissive
and i before i start i just want to
remind everybody these are my rules not
yours
they should sound kind of crazy if
you're listening to them
so one of them is you know always have
one year of emergency fund cash
okay fine this you could make it six
months or a year whatever
but here's another one never question
spending money on books
appetizers health or donating to a
friend's charity fundraiser
now each of those is very meaningful to
me because i didn't grow up being able
to afford
appetizers so now if i eat out with
friend or whoever i say look
whatever you like on the menu just order
it and that feels
amazing what does it cost me an extra 20
bucks but it feels incredible
and then there's some really big ones
like anytime i take a flight over four
hours
business class or be able to pay in
full for large expenses including a
wedding
dream honeymoon or even a house okay
those are really big rich life
dreams and rules most people are
listening like hey i'm not going to pay
all cash for a house
totally fine what i would challenge each
person as they think about their rich
life is
i would love for them to say you know
what every week
i love fresh flowers it feels a little
indulgent to me
but it just makes me feel so good and so
i'm gonna buy fresh flowers for myself
every week
beautiful i'm kind of smirking as you
say that because i'm going to tilt this
i'm not sure if you'll be able to see it
but uh oh look at that
beautiful sunflower yeah there's a
bouquet of flowers
right in front of me and that was
actually a
recent decision it's like flowers each
week
completely changes my experience
of my home why just having
a symbol of life and vibrancy also of
change and having something to care for
if you're changing the water
it really just fundamentally changes my
experience of space and aesthetics
in the home and it's such a simple thing
so that's why i'm smiling
i love it you know what every time i ask
people their rich life
and i probe their first answers are
never what we ultimately settle on
but as we start talking about it and we
spend a lot of time really probing and
pushing why that well what if you
dreamed a little bigger and they also
smile the whole time because no one has
ever asked him
what is your rich life and really asked
him why
never so usually if it's something like
a handbag
right something tangible most people
start off by saying like this
well i know i mean i guess i'd like a
purse it doesn't have to be like the
fanciest purse but
you know i'd like this handbag and like
maybe once every decade it could be like
a nice one
and i go what if it was every year
and what if it was that brand the the
most
beautiful version of it and their eyes
light up because no one has ever
talked to them about the thing that deep
down they love what i call their money
dial
instead it's kind of seen as frivolous
particularly things like handbags which
i don't agree with i think
you could buy a beautiful handbag for
the craftsmanship for the functionality
or just cause you want it
for those people who can't see ramirez
now he's winking at me
so i know what to get you for christmas
thank you very much please continue and
you know i'm
hoping as i'm asking these questions
that their partner
is seeing and can model this
because you'll usually find that when
one partner is
nervous because they think that it's
frivolous that there's a reason for that
that their partner has said something
multiple times in the past like
well why do you don't need a handbag
like that you don't need that kind of
car
and yeah you don't need it but we're
here talking about your rich life to
start
we're going to get to the spreadsheet
stuff we're going to get to your
spending plan
but let's just start off with your
vision of what a rich life is
that is exciting so if we rewind just
back to the
blueprint here not so much a blueprint
but your series of questions
within the last 30 days where have you
not been on the same page
right financially what does your rich
life look like
what are some of the questions that
follow or could follow after that
usually when i find that one person
is an over spender and they admit it
themselves
i ask them have you ever said no
and what i mean by that is have you ever
said no to
your family who's asking you for money
or have you ever said no
to your partner when they ask for xyz
have you ever said no and almost always
they say
no i've never done that so you realize
at that very moment that there's a
deeper issue than
just money it's being a people pleaser
it's not being able to set effective
boundaries
things like that we get into that i also
ask people
how big of an issue is this on a scale
of one to ten and this is a really
interesting response i get in this case
what is this
the thing that they disagreed on within
the last 30 days yeah
yeah okay and almost always
they will say it's like a five out of
ten
it's not that bad now remember they've
gotten on a podcast
with me where they're sharing real
numbers they're sharing
fights and and challenges they've had
for years
and they're going oh it's a five out of
ten so i know
that there's something going on here i
say okay five out of ten
what do you think happens if you know
you both disagree about
how much to spend at brunch on saturdays
what do you think happens when you have
kids and then when you decide to
move to a different city and when you
have 25 years of this
going on what happens and they go oh
yeah that's like a 9 out of 10.
i go yeah and what do you think happens
at 9 out of 10
and they realize that when people say we
got divorced because of money
it was not fighting over seven dollars
at target
but it started there and it calcified
over 25 years
that could be the title of your next
book it could be seven dollars at target
small disagreements and how they lead to
big divorces oh you are the best at
titles tim
i'll take my customary 15 it's very
reasonable
because we're friends
all right any other questions they'd
like to cover no that's where we start
that gives me a lay of the land
and i can kind of walk you through an
exercise that i do with them
may be helpful if you think let's do it
all right great so this is one that i
actually started
with my wife and we were talking about
our rich life and it's hard when you
start talking about your rich life
because you don't even know where to
start
many of us have spent our entire lives
being told what we can't do with our
money
so when you ask people what they want to
do the answers are fairly facile
you know the whole foods is an example
so what i did was i said okay
let's take separate pieces of paper and
let's write down
in the next 10 years what's on our
bucket list
and let's just write it down and we took
10 15 minutes
and the way that i thought of this was i
was inspired by stephen king's
national book club speech now he was
living in a trailer
with his wife and he was running out of
money
and he got a job offer to be a teacher
and his wife said to him will you be
able to write
and he said no i won't but at least
it'll allow us to pay the bills
and she instantly said well then you
can't do it
wow and so that chilling moment
and then fast forward just a little bit
in the future he signs
a massive deal for his first book a
massive deal
he gets the check brings it home to his
wife
in their trailer and he said we sat
there
we looked at the check we talked about
what we were going to do with the money
and we cried he said it was one of the
most beautiful conversations of his life
and i love that i love the idea that
money can be this thing that lets us do
more
not less it lets us dream bigger lets us
be more adventurous more
generous so i started off with my wife i
said let's just write down our bucket
list items
okay so we come back after 15 minutes
she had some interesting ones she wanted
to learn another language
that was just individually for herself
together
you know we wanted to i think i wrote
down i want to design a house
with you because she's very creative and
we're both into design
and we wanted to have a beautiful
10-year wedding anniversary
in india we know the exact place we know
all the people that we want to bring
with us
great we're talking about this we're
loving it we're having a blast
and i said let's pick a couple of these
and let's
put a dollar value to them so we picked
the
ten year wedding anniversary and i said
okay
pick a number there's no way to know the
right number but just pick a number what
you think it'll cost
so she kind of takes a second i take a
second and
the numbers that we picked were
hilariously different
my number was something like five to ten
times
bigger than the number my wife picked
and she looked uncomfortable like
visibly uncomfortable
yeah i was gonna ask you if there's an
asymmetry
of wealth i would imagine the person who
has
fewer resources may be very nervous
about actually speaking honestly or
adding big items or offering big numbers
well
you're totally right most people are
afraid of
dreaming about their rich life at all
because they feel that once they write
it down
or tell someone if they don't achieve it
then they're a failure
but in my opinion that's just going
through life playing defense
and i'd rather play offense so what i
said to my wife is like look
neither of us know what this is actually
going to cost we just made these numbers
up
but if we're going to choose a number
let's go with the bigger one why because
we have a lot of time we have eight plus
years to save and invest for this
two i think we can do it i know what we
can accomplish
together we could do it and three
wouldn't it be magical to be able to
take
all of our friends and family the people
who can't afford it just go to the
airport and the ticket will be there for
you
wouldn't that be amazing and so really
coming back to that
vision instead of well it's actually
going to be seven percent return and i
don't know
no this is a vision exercise so she
begrudgingly said
okay i will say that
one year later my wife has done an
amazing job working on her money
psychology
and we kind of revisited this and she
said
oh yeah like now i know without a doubt
we can hit that number
easily and that's when you're really
aligned with your partner where the two
of you are rowing in the same direction
it's not one person saying come on but
it's both of us saying oh yeah we could
do this
so let me ask may i ask you a very
personal uncomfortable
possibly uncomfortable question and then
you can tell me okay
so you said we can hit the number right
was there a discussion with some of
these items of how each
party sort of contributes to that big
goal
right even though you're not getting
into immediately the nitty-gritty i
understand it's a vision exercise but
since you're using the example i figured
i might as well ask
because i bet this is something that is
going to be an inevitable
topic that people have to navigate okay
i'm glad you asked and i'll definitely
share how we did it
so i think that the reason that we
came up with these joint goals
like a 10-year wedding anniversary is
that we
both want to contribute to it okay we
want to contribute proportionally
based on income but we both want to
contribute
to it the thing about you know my wife
wants to learn a certain language
i'm not contributing to that she makes
what language
just out of curiosity spanish okay cool
yeah she's taking a class she's doing a
great job nice
and she decided to get her own tutor and
that's her thing and she's covering that
on her own and i'm
thrilled i have my own stuff that i pay
for again we have our join accounts and
our separate accounts
but i will say that the reason that i
wanted to
have this exercise is that when we meet
once a month to talk about our finances
we have something to look forward to
we have an exact number that we are
saving and investing
together for and we look at it it's
almost like one of those progress bars
okay we're four percent of the way there
oh my gosh we're
now eight percent of the way there and
we can see that this goal which was so
big originally we're actually just
chipping away at it day by day
that's magic so the the once monthly
meeting to discuss finances i want to
hear more about this yeah what's the
format
okay the four so you and i talked on our
last podcast about
checking in and you had some great
suggestions for some questions and
we've used those and adapted those for
our own relationship
it's one thing to do a relationship
check-in yep i also think another really
valuable check-in is a financial
check-in
and so the way that we do it is we
have a spreadsheet that we've built
it's custom for us based on what we
what's important to us so we have our
expenses that are in there
in the course of a 30 minute call
we will look over our expenses and the
call by the way is with a third party
who kind of walks us through some of the
the numbers the expenses take five
minutes
because really most of our expenses are
planned for okay i'll give you an
example except for your handbags
except for the handbags that's right
well those are going to be an incoming
gift from
tim ferriss soon enough my my
private label handbag line i can't
believe you've told the world
that's right so here's the thing i think
about expenses i think most people
they spend time all their time looking
at expenses
and it's really depressing yeah this is
the wrong place to spend
a lot of time what we did instead was we
said okay our groceries are basically
the same
every single month our whatever rent is
basically the same
every single month there's a couple
areas that are variable
so we actually sat down at the end of
the year and we planned out
how many trips do we want to take how
much is each of those trips
and we kind of got we got pretty
granular about it
we also know that some surprise expenses
come up with things like
gifts so we planned it out appropriately
ahead of time this is how many people
we're going to give gifts to this is the
amount we're going to gift
charity same thing and so those are
baked in so on a given month
yeah we might be a little bit over on
food we might be a little bit under on
gas but it's basically within parameters
okay after five minutes of that we spend
way more time looking at our rich life
goals
so we have about five rich life goals
that are
actively being saved for that would be
like the 10-year wedding anniversary
and so each quarter each month or
quarter we have money going into those
goals
and then we have a backlog you can never
have too many rich life goals
because at some point we're gonna hit
one of those goals
what's next guess what we got our
backlog ready to go
and so that backlog could be you know
hiring somebody to do xyz for us
it could be taking this special trip
buying a new car
this type of specific car and model it's
all there
what would be your true but
most embarrassing backlog rich life goal
to share on this podcast right now
oh my god um
this is horrifying let me think okay
well my
okay so once i sat down and i asked my
friends i was like what is
what is the next level for you the rich
life next level
and so one one of them was like i want
to jet and one of them was like i want
to
take a trip to tahiti or something like
that and mine was uh
i never want to have to pack a suitcase
again in my life
and they're like are you stupid that's
like 50 bucks
but okay i'll tell you what it is now
the suitcase part
i don't want to have to carry luggage
when i travel
okay that and that's relatively
inexpensive you can ship it for like 100
bucks
i don't i just don't want to i want to
walk out of an airplane
free and not sweating because i have a
like a bag that i'm carrying around with
me that was a very
i don't know it feels a little indulgent
to me but it's like a hundred bucks
okay so so shipping luggage as opposed
to transporting luggage
correct yeah i know i know a few people
who've
done that for many many years they
refuse
they refuse i know one also who hates to
select clothing to travel with so
he wears black shirt tan cargo pants
uh every day kind of steve jobs with uh
like a limp biscuit
twist to it and and uh
same shoes and so his assistant will
pack
i guess their gallon ziploc bags or
something like that with
each day's outfit because he hates doing
laundry also so he just has
all of these versions of the same outfit
and so if he's going on like a 10-day
trip there will be 10
gallon ziploc bags with each day's
outfit this is not what i thought was
going to be his rich life
but god bless you i mean all the best
that's why it's his rich life
for me all right okay so that so that's
what we do so
we um we start off with the expenses
like five minutes we spend more time on
the rich life
goals and then we have an open backlog
of questions you know there's sometimes
things like
hey we've got this trip coming up like
do we want to stay here there or like
should we get this or that things like
that
we have a document a running document
that we just track these questions on
and usually within 30 sometimes 60
minutes
we're good to go for about a month
that's roughly the structure
i would encourage it for anybody and i
want to add a twist for people
when you do these meetings it can be
really depressing
because talking about money for most
people is really negative why did you
spend this much we don't want that at
all we want this to be a positive
experience
so i would encourage if possible you
know go out to dinner
or if you have children and you have the
ability to maybe get some help for
one hour two hours take advantage of
that
this is supposed to be a positive
experience where you can say you know
what
i really want to talk about money in a
way that benefits both of us
and i would love to get your input what
can we do to make this
a great environment for us to have this
conversation
do that and you're going to be way more
set than having it with
dinner on the table and people screaming
that's not going to be conducive to this
type of meeting
so let's say that you both
want that to be the case let's just
assume
and this is not from my my personal
experience just to be clear but
i would imagine there are cases where
you have a couple and one person
is an overspender maybe it extends
further than that like you said maybe
their people pleaser they don't have
clear boundaries with other folks but
nonetheless like the
the hemorrhaging is coming predominantly
from
one side what's what type of
conversation
would you recommend for people in that
type of situation
this is really hard but this is the most
common of all
to have these conversations it's usually
one person
effectively dragging the other person to
the meeting all right so
that's not a good place to start and
i'll tell you what the
typical approach is and then what a
better approach is the typical approach
is to say hey
we really need to get a handle on your
spending this is not working
so let's talk about money okay that's
never going to work so just stop that
right now
another approach would be to say okay i
built this spreadsheet model
look at tab 16 it'll show you all the
math and right now we're compounding
don't do that nobody cares about
compounding
you haven't earned the right to talk
about math
at this first conversation the third and
i think much better approach is to say
you know what babe
i've been listening to this podcast
episode and
they were talking about money they were
talking about a rich life
and you know i i guess i never thought
about it this way
you know there was one woman who said
she wanted to be able to go to whole
foods
and just spend without looking at the
prices
i mean you've mentioned that right what
would that feel like to you
you know for me a rich life would be to
be able to
get in the car and drive and if we see a
place we like
we can just stop there and we can order
whatever we want
without looking at how much it costs
like i would love to do that with you
so what would it be for you you know i'd
love to know
let's just pause right there notice that
in that
conversation that we just had a couple
things i did in a couple things i didn't
do
first i set the context why am i
bringing this up
feel free to throw the tim ferriss show
under the bus oh i was listening to this
weird show
some guy came on ramit sethi i don't
know okay do that
give give them a reason number two i was
genuinely curious you know hey i know
you've mentioned whole foods what would
that be like for you
i find in couples that have trouble they
have rarely
asked the other partner a question
a single question in months if not years
okay so that's number two notice what i
didn't do i did not talk about i mean
questions about money or no any
questions
anything when i talk to them i'll give
one of the one of the young women in my
um
episodes she revealed that she had an
alcoholic father
and she had she and her family had had
to walk around on eggshells
because of him she said if we're really
getting real that's
that's how i was raised and you know
what happened her husband
started talking over her well yeah you
know that's why i really wanted to have
the courage to be an entrepreneur
i said man are you listening right now
did you know about that he goes no i go
would you like to maybe ask her
any type of question about this
bombshell she just dropped
which by the way reveals everything
about the trouble they were having
and he struggled to ask the question
his question to her was how do
i help you achieve my goals
i was like wow okay we're going to start
at ground and so tough kiss
tough case very tough doctor but you
know you know what i think um sometimes
people in relationships they do want it
to be successful but they need a little
modeling
they need to see what it looks like to
actually ask
a single curiosity-based question and so
we worked through it
and eventually he said this is the
question he asked which i was so happy
about he said
what do you mean that's all it was it
was as simple as that what do you mean
i said we've been talking for an hour
and a half that was the first time
you've asked a single question
of your wife and i loved it so
this curiosity thing is another thing
that happens
and as you kind of get into these
conversations with people you realize
boy we have these patterns that we've
been repeating for months
oftentimes years and if we need a third
party to help us
or if we can just switch locations let's
go to a nice dinner
and talk about it listen to this podcast
suddenly you can kind of turn the leaf
and start that process
of building a new relationship with
money okay so
couldn't agree more i've had to train
myself to be better at this
if at some point though you need to get
to the er
to triage and stop the financial
hemorrhaging
you you can go like directly through the
worst
neighborhood yelling and screaming to
the er you can also take a detour
through like the amusement park
and make the entry a little easier but
eventually you get to the er
and the fact remains that one person is
spending a lot more
than the other when
they get to that crux or at the point
that
that is to be the topic of conversation
how have you seen people do that
successfully in the past
you are right there actually actually
let me let me ask a better question
because that
that implies a bunch of things need to
happen and maybe they don't
how do you see people successfully solve
that situation
that's a better question ultimately
if they're going to solve it together
they both have to
want to create a vision a north star
together
it is extremely unlikely basically i've
never seen it where one person drags
their partner
and makes it happen it does not happen
it can work for a while
but the rest of your life fighting about
everything from the cost of starbucks
and a candle
to the cost of who's paying for our kids
college
it's just a dreadful life and um
and that's exactly why people end up
getting divorced among many other
reasons when it comes to money
what i find is that of the people who
change successfully one there is a
desire to change
and that's why i ask them why now right
it's never about the dishwasher
it's them realizing that oh we don't
have the tools to do this
or oftentimes it's them with their son
or daughter
who will make a comment and they realize
that their toxic money behavior is
actually being picked up by their kids
that's a really common one okay and any
examples
one young woman said to me that her
son came up to mom
and said don't tell daddy about
buying this there was a lot of hiding
money and spending in their relationship
just like there had been
with mom's parents so it's passed down
generationally
and when i pointed it out to them i said
you know
you two could probably make it work over
the course of your life you know you're
both very resourceful you're high
earners
but how do you think your children are
responding to this and their
faces went completely white and they
looked at each other and they knew
they knew they said oh yeah my son
already knows about this he told me the
other day
don't tell daddy about spending and so
that was the thing that got them to make
the change
so by the way it's not enough to just
want to change like everybody
wants to have this smooth relationship
with money
where we can be you know abundant and
live our rich life
but i also find that there's a
combination of wanting to change
psychology and use tools and systems
so psychology a lot of us think that
it's weird
to have a meeting about money once a
month or once a quarter
it's weird you know what you know the
way that most people are raised is you
don't talk about money until there's a
fight
that's the predominant world view on
money and couples
in this country and so when you shift it
and you say
yeah you're gonna have a standing agenda
you two are actually gonna have a google
doc
one of the most common reactions i get
is that sounds like a job
sounds like work i go yeah that's
because at work you're measured on
certain things
you're trying to bring some of that into
your relationship you can still
love your partner and sleep next to them
but you can still have a running agenda
so that's one changing that psychology
the second is using these systems
you know usually when i find that um
people are i'm speaking to these couples
who have some type of big major money
problem
they are not aligned on basic financial
principles and they're not
using like basic systems things like
they don't understand compounding so one
of them goes well late let's just like
spend our money because we don't know
how long we're going to be here for
or we'll never make enough and i point
out if you guys started saving and
investing properly today you'd have like
six million dollars
they go what so that's number one two is
just you know using things like
do we have a shared spreadsheet things
like that i i had another couple that
was extremely financially sophisticated
they were in the realm of being cpas
and i asked them how much money do you
think you make
what's your net worth and the answer
between the two of them was off by
millions of dollars remember these are
highly sophisticated people
so i said i said why is that and um
the answer is that they are so
sophisticated they
had all these exceptions well this one
is here but this is liquid and this is
not
i said guys you got to go back to first
grade create a one-page google
doc like basically right on it with
crayon this is how much we have
this is how much we owe this is how much
you know we've invested
and they had to kind of accept that even
though they're super advanced at work
in their personal life they need to
start back at ground zero can you think
of an example
of a serious fight
it doesn't have to be from your personal
experience but in your experience with
all the readers and various couples and
so on something that was
a 9 out of 10 in severity that had a
really simple solution that worked
yes yeah does that make sense like
something something that's
that that had been intractable right
this couple had been smashing their head
against a brick wall
or against it's been smashing each
other's heads together
and at an impasse and then lo and behold
there was a simple solution
there's a couple who lives
on the upper east side of new york all
right
the complaint was he
has been starting a business i need him
to contribute
a hundred dollars a month to the
household
for food things like that they have two
children okay
and he said look i'm putting everything
i've got
into this business so she was very upset
because she's like look we're going in
the red every month
now i asked him a couple questions i
said how much does your apartment cost
the rent was 3 800 a month they were
making
70 000 per year oh wow yeah
okay so all right well what's that's
probably here
they have been pre-tax that's pre-tax
correct they have been
fighting about a hundred dollars
per month that has been a debate in
their household for
something like nine months and there
were a lot of tears
there were a lot of real agonizing
conversations
but you know what the real problem was
they were bankrupt
in two months and they didn't even know
it
wow so this is a really difficult
conversation we had
and the solution was very very tough
which was
she had a conception of how she was
going to live
her family lived very close to her she
could visit them every day
but the truth was they needed to move
out of the city and likely move out of
the state
and go to a much lower cost of living
now imagine how it feels
to have your entire world that you've
constructed and the plan
for you your husband your children and
then on this call you realize
that is not going to happen it's
devastating
it's very tough and so you know they put
me in a position of trust to be able to
talk to them
and one of the things i told them was
look it doesn't mean that you have to
move away forever
there are lots of things you could do
with this company make it successful
increase your income but you can't
ignore that this is
the real problem in the relationship
ignoring it will not make it go away
it'll just get
way worse and so it really goes to show
that there are things that we can
agonize over for
weeks or months or even years in our
relationship but sometimes the true
problem
is way out there in left field
what did they do do you have any idea i
will follow up with them
soon and i hope to do follow-up episodes
where we find out
what actually happened post-mortem
could be could be the second podcast
what are some of the other situations
that you've run into
and actually i'd be curious after our
last conversation related to
prenups although we covered many topics
not just prenups
was there any feedback or
subsequent learnings from people who
heard it
or people who read your writing that
you found interesting puzzling
thought-provoking
or otherwise well the first and most
important
reaction that i got was people
recognizing that prenups are not just
some rich
[ __ ] trying to screw their partner
and i was i was really happy about that
and i want to thank you for letting me
come on and
kind of share my own personal experience
because the only way most people hear
about prenups is
from tv and it's super untrue and
dramatic the way that it's portrayed
and so i saw a lot of comments on reddit
on my instagram
dms people saying like hey i had no idea
that's how it actually works
so that was very gratifying again as i
said in the episode most people don't
need a prenup
okay but if you do if you're coming in
with a pre-existing business or a
disproportionate amount of wealth
then it's worth talking about it and a
prenup is something you agree on
or side note if you may inherit any
asset from your family
yep also totally right so it could be
real estate could be a house
it could be anything yeah also also
consideration
you know sometimes i read a lot of
reddit and sometimes i see these
conversations where
um one person goes my partner wants me
to sign a prenup
and i think that they're an [ __ ] i'm
gonna break up with them
and then of course there are like
hundreds and hundreds of comments and
once in a while i will see someone
reference that episode and that makes me
really happy whether it's that episode
or another place that
someone's really talking about this
stuff i think there's slowly being a
shift
where people are starting to recognize
hey this isn't just [ __ ]
oh so and for people who i'm sure it's
easy enough to find but we'll create a
short link it's not legal advice folks
but it is a fun conversation and very
very detailed tim.log
forward slash prenup we will just make a
short link for people who are interested
so that'll go straight to that episode
what other
tools questions exercises
resources anything that you think
might be beneficial to listeners of this
episode the broad
topic being couples and finance couples
and money
what other ground might we cover let's
talk about
what i call the 100 challenge and this
is for people who tend to struggle
spending money on themselves
now i can help
people with their investments i can help
them change their money psychology
i can often fix their businesses but if
there's one thing i cannot fix
it's cheap i can't fix cheap people if
you're cheap i can't help you
i'm sorry well you can help them but you
can't fix them unless they want
to be fixed but here's the thing yeah
here's the thing they
never want to change it
so cheap people they write me tim this
is the one group of people i've just
decided
i cannot help them because they right
now there are levels and there are
levels right
uh yeah that's true okay we're talking
about like nba all-star cheap
meaning yeah maybe that's not the right
metaphor to use but
you're talking maybe you could just give
some examples of what we're talking
about
i mean throw out the car deal because we
didn't get the floor mats that kind of
no no not that not that although i don't
think my dad thinks there's anything
wrong with that
uh so i guess i'm proving my own that's
a true story i'm proving my own point as
i say this
um it is people who write and they say
hey we've you know saved a bunch of
money and
but i can't bring myself to spend it
um and i and so you know i developed all
these variety of techniques and i say
you know what will you do with the money
and they acknowledge that it's
irrational
but when i give them something to do
about it
they ultimately go oh actually it's fine
they don't think that's that big of a
problem they minimize it
so i'm going to give everybody a 100
challenge here to try to preempt
this problem before you become a cheap
ass you take this challenge right now
and you can
take that fork in the road towards a
rich life instead of whatever cheap
place you're about to go to so here's
here's the challenge
in the next 48 hours i want you to spend
a hundred dollars on something you love
you cannot spend it on kids you cannot
spend it on pets
and you cannot spend it on charities
it has to be on you now if you're a high
earner
you can take that number and you can
multiply it so for example if i'm going
to tim i'm not giving tim the 100
challenge tim's challenge has a lot more
zeros on it okay and so
so you you can just finally get can
finally get that botox i've been eyeing
you can decide what the amount is but
the point is it should be
meaningful right it should make you
think and it should make you go oh
wow what am i going to spend that on and
this is just
one little way one method
to start shifting your life towards
spending on the things that are
important to you
you know a lot of people they're 30 40
50 they go i don't actually know what i
want to spend on
and i find that to be a tragedy
i think it's a tragedy to live a smaller
life than you have to
so here they are with hundreds of
thousands even millions of dollars in
the bank
and almost as part of their identity
well i don't you know i'm fine i just
eat a taco bell
listen i ate at taco bell a long time
myself it's great okay
but what else can you do with your money
and really
dream into something bigger more
meaningful
it could be luxurious it could be
adventurous
whatever the case may be that's what i
want for you doing this 100
challenge so if if that were posed to
you
and i'm sure people have asked you this
right what would or what have been some
of your answers
oh good question um besides besides the
luggage concierge aka fedex
yeah great question so so my number
would be bigger than 100
i would probably do one thousand to five
thousand dollars
and in that price range what i would do
is
i would there's a few things that i have
done so one is i would take an
a last minute trip wherever just to see
a friend
right i'm gonna get on a plane and go
wherever they live in the world
and just hang with them it could be as
short as two days it could be five ten
days
that's very abundant for me two is i
love clothes
so i would go and buy the most beautiful
coat or sweater
that i've had my eye on boom i always
have a list of things that i'm like
that's i'll get that next and three i
love convenience
so it would be you know for example
hiring uh
a travel agent and saying okay this is
the type of trip i want give me the
entire itinerary laid out
that's what i would do what about you
you know i was gonna say i came across
an amazing cashmere onesie
that i think would look amazing on you i
need to tell you something about this
because
okay years ago do you remember that site
guilt
guilt.com i do okay yeah yeah
guilt group exactly so i um i
at one point i signed up and i mentioned
it in my email list
and i became one of their top referrers
overnight
and so basically i had like unlimited
money on guilt for years
okay so at one point they were they were
selling meat
so you know high-end meat so i just
order meat and just like send it to my
sisters i'm like hey
keep your eye out in the mail today you
know just crazy stuff
and so one day i said you know what i
really need
from guilt group is a cashmere blanket
that's what i need okay so i go on there
and and it was there and i ordered it
okay tim this blanket comes alright of
course it's beautifully wrapped
and i open it up and it's the size
of slightly larger than a
facial washcloth and i go i go no
i go this cannot be like because it was
folded into itself you know it's very
very premium
and i go this cannot be i must be
missing one of the unwrapping things
so i keep turning it and pulling at
stuff nothing
and i i go back and look at the size the
size is correct
and i was like what in the hell is this
stupid thing
okay it turns out it was a cashmere
swaddle blanket for a newborn
yes these exist i was like this is
crazy who the hell would buy this so i
don't have that cashmere blanket tim i
returned it
but somebody out there actually bought
it well that's why i thought the
cashmere onesie with the crotch snap
release would be perfect for you
so dvd i don't wanna i don't wanna give
too much
tmi on on the podcast this is family
programming after all
uh what would mine be uh
well i i actually i mean this might be
cheating but i kind of know
in the sense that i i have something
like this which is something i've
already committed to although it remains
to be seen whether the travel is going
to work
but to have an incredibly gifted
musician and teacher come spend
a week with me to do intensive
hand drumming training at least twice a
day no kidding
and it's not cheap
but it's not collecting ferraris
right it's it's it's something that i
think
i i don't think i know even five years
ago i probably would have hesitated to
do
for whatever reason perhaps putting it
in the frivolous category
well i think let's be honest right you
don't you said i i need a cashmere
blanket you don't need a cashmere
blanket you want a cashmere correct
and there's nothing wrong with that
great no there's nothing wrong with it
but i think for me i i would have
criticized myself for the expense and
the travel
and everything else involved because
i think in part just didn't grow up with
a lot of resources you know certainly
enough we had shelter and warm clothes
and everything else but
that that would be one example okay so
many things i love about that
first of all the fact that you have a
clear vision of it
i love that the second that it's
meaningful to you
that makes no sense to me but i love
that it makes
perfect sense to you i love that that
the more
dialed in your rich life becomes the
more incomprehensible it should become
to everybody else so that was beautiful
and then
the other thing i love is that it really
kind of becomes part of your identity
you and i have talked a lot
offline about growing up and you know
the way that we grew up was totally
different than silicon valley and all
this kind of stuff that we've become a
little bit more exposed to
and you take that with you i certainly
have taken it with me
i don't want to just drop money
frivolously on
everything but if there's anything i
would say that
is impressive about what you said it's
that you have
changed your identity from where you
came from
which was great but now you're at a
different place
and it's also great to honor that and
say i can still be the tim
that grew up over here but i've achieved
a lot i've been
fortunate i've been lucky i've worked
hard and i get to
reap the rewards of that for myself and
for the people around me
i think that is an amazing answer thanks
man it's uh
it's also one that i've tested so this
would be the second time that i've done
it and i think it's
worth noting probably that this isn't
the
90 of your net worth challenge this is
the 100
challenge or the fill in the blank
challenge which is
enough to make you perhaps a little
uncomfortable
if you're used to being frugal but it's
not enough to do any real damage
so you can actually test and so i tested
it there are other things i've tested
that have not been replicated
for instance like there are some really
fancy meals i've gone to them or like
no i'm never going to go back to that
place like i i don't i don't need to do
that twice
i don't think it was worth it in this
case i decided it was worth it it helped
me
further develop a skill which then
persisted after the fact
the teacher himself is is amazing and
he's just fun to spend time with
and some of the experiences we had like
doing an impromptu
impromptu like duet jam session at a
friend's house with a bunch of wine
our our memories i really really cherish
so that one made the cut
love it therefore here we go again round
two yeah this is what i want
everybody listening to be able to do is
just like tim
he tried out a fancy restaurant hey
tried it once
it didn't break the bank cool i did it i
don't need to go back there again
on the other hand i tried this thing
boom great that is so different than
a life of frugality which is often coded
for
fear the fear that if i go to this
michelin-starred restaurant
once that i'm going to trip and fall and
have to go back there every single day
for the rest of my life
that does not happen my friends and you
can just as well say
no to things once you've tasted them you
can also say
yes to other things and i love that so
for couples this is doubly hard
because it's not just you but it's your
partner
right i remember speaking to one couple
and they had not gone on a honeymoon yet
even though they were married and they
were talking about where to go and one
of them
goes yeah let's go to i think it was
indonesia
let's go for like four weeks we'll have
a blast and
his partner says four weeks that's kind
of long we'll get bored right
uh two should be enough now think about
listening to a couple where one person
is actually excited about a honeymoon
and the other's first reaction is to
minimize their partners dreams
that is a really common they weren't
intending
to basically stomp on their partner but
they did and so i just kind of gently
said hey why don't we try this again and
this time let's both get excited right
you're excited over
here let's get excited as well and
instead of going into a downward spiral
it went into an
upward spiral hey what if we did that oh
my gosh and what if we
also rented a car and we did this
and you could see and hear the energy
change
so again if you are going out for your
first conversation with your partner
you know one of the things you might
agree on is hey today
just for the next hour let's agree that
we're gonna pump each other up
we're not going to minimize each other
we're just going to pump each other up
that's all and that can profoundly
change your interactions about money
what other advice so we talked about the
100 challenge this is in the next 48
hours has to be for you
you can't dodge it and kind of deflect
it to
another entity whether it's your partner
your kids
your dog there's that what other
tools exercises questions do you have
for people
who have trouble spending money
now that might sound strange but
ultimately money is this
piece of symbolism that we trade for
something else
yeah whether it's a feeling or an
experience which is usually
upstream of a yet another feeling you
interviewed a couple
as i understand it that saved millions
of dollars but they seem unable to enjoy
it
yeah they have not had a vacation in the
last decade right or people who struggle
over small expenses
well what are some other tools in the
toolkit or questions approaches that you
use in cases like that
and this might sound really strange to
people like it's rarefied air right they
might be like ah
like they're taking this conversation in
a direction that will not relate to
anyone
but that's in my experience not true i
think the
the developing competency and comfort
with
translating dollars into value whether
that is through
investing or spending
which is oftentimes another type of
investing i think is a skill that you
develop i don't think anyone has it
innately right so this applies to many
more but
since i believe you've interviewed this
particular couple what other tools do
you have in the toolkit
besides the 100 challenge so first i
have a lot of compassion for them
because
everybody teaches us how to save but
nobody teaches us how to spend
spending is a skill and you know my
dream
is to take someone who's made money
and take them out in new york for two or
three days and
show them how to spend money
commensurate with the level that they
are
at now please do not dm me and ask me to
take you out in new york or la
i'm not doing that anymore tim if you
want to do that but i think you spend
money fine but please don't dm me and
ask for
a free tour you know i'll make a
confession just real quick
so i think i'm actually it has been very
hard for me to learn how to spend money
very challenging and in fact i'm
interrupting so don't lose train of
thought but the reason i'm interrupting
is that literally this past weekend
was the first maybe the first time ever
i have done like a
proper weekend in new york
city with my girlfriend really yeah wait
is this is this about to happen
are you and i gonna have a romantic
adventure where i'm gonna
you know we're gonna like go to a
broadway show together
and well i mean i'm open to that i
literally just did this though this past
how did it feel it felt [ __ ] amazing
and uh
it was it was outstanding and we had so
much fun and it brought us closer
and you know there are things we would
do again and some things we wouldn't do
again but ultimately
it was affordable and
like why are we collecting all these m
ms like you can
if not to ultimately use them in some
fashion and that's not to say you don't
save i mean i've spent my whole life
saving
right but as you said like you just
don't you're getting the first piece of
the puzzle but then you have to figure
out the rest of it
please continue so so thrilled to hear
that and it doesn't matter whether the
amount
is you know ten thousand dollars that
you save
or a much larger amount invariably if
you've been saving
and or investing for a while you will
ultimately have an amount where you have
to decide what to do with it
and most of us spend our entire lives
focusing on just the saving part
but i think probably every single one of
us has a parent
or a relative or somebody older than us
who does not know how to enjoy their
money
and they still drive around town to save
money on gas
and you say look you've got enough what
are you gonna do with it and then
ultimately they will say something like
well i guess i'll just give it to my
kids
your kids don't want the money they want
you to have a good life
they want you to spend it on the things
you love and so that's why
i'm so passionate about this in fairness
some of the kids want the money
but a lot of kids also want their
parents to have a great okay i did not
make an allowance for those people
they're like counting the clock
oh that's sad so you know i have found
that you cannot tell people who struggle
with spending money
hey guys you really need to spend more
money it's just it goes in one ear and
out the other it's
not even a factor in their life that's
why i spend so much time saying
what's your rich life it's very much
like the same you can't tell someone who
loves chocolate cake
cut out the chocolate cake instead we
say hey let's add a little bit more
delicious chicken
let's add some really good asparagus
yeah you still want the chocolate cake
cool
but it's probably gonna just naturally
become a little bit less of a part on
the plate
so when i when i talk about their rich
life when i understand the texture
the color i don't want them to say
travel
i want them to say i'm going to
indonesia for four weeks with my
beautiful wife
we're going to sit in c2a or 2d
and this is where we're going to stay
and this is what we're going to do and
we're even going to have
a food tour and we're going to do this
and that
now it's vivid vivid enough that they
get excited about it
i also use the stick where i say okay
right now you're 38 years old
this was a couple that i spoke to and i
said by my calculations
by the time you're in your 60s you will
have
over 26 million dollars
when are you gonna start spending your
money
and they looked at each other and he
goes well probably when i retire
and i just point blank said to him i
don't believe you do you believe him
and the wife said no i don't believe of
course i don't believe he can't even
spend his money right now
and so what i encourage them and what i
showed them was would you rather end up
at 60 with some amount of money or would
you rather end up at 60 with just a
little bit less money but a lifetime
worth of experience ultimately when i'm
speaking to people like this who find it
difficult
they're just afraid afraid that they'll
lose it all and as i probed him you know
what he told me
his dad had lost all of his money late
in life
so you often find these family
challenges that they cannot escape from
how did he lose his money do you
remember how did his dad listen he was
in another country
and he made a series of bad investments
and bad deals
and lost it all so they've constantly
lived with this fear
as by the way all of us do based on the
cues we were raised with
that you know i could lose it all or
that i'll never be rich
or that the rich are all evil and those
are some of those invisible scripts that
we have to work through if we want to
work with our partner together towards a
rich life
where should we go next let me share
just a couple of my
biggest fascinations that i've taken
away from these couples
these are the patterns that i've noticed
which which really surprised me
because i thought there would be a
couple but not these ones
the first pattern is that people will
work for years and years and years
save their money but never think about
what they want to do with it
one couple they said that their rich
life is that they want to own
four cottages eventually and i said
cool what do you want to do with that
they go i wanted to throw off passive
income
so that eventually we can buy this
beautiful rv and go camping
with our family i said that sounds cool
how old will your kids be you know from
the sounds of it their kids would be
like 65 years old by the time they could
do this
i said can i make another suggestion
what if
you rent an rv you go
for two and a half weeks and you do it
18 months from now after you've saved
the money to do it
they had built up this vision of that
they had to buy four cottages and then
buy an rv
to go camping with their kids the kids
would damn near be dead
by the time they could do that just go
rent the rv and go and see if you like
it
okay so that's one is we save and save
and don't think about it
the next is we often have a ghost in the
relationship
often times there's a third party
in this relationship and i encourage
them to name the ghost
one of the couples name their ghost
franny and franny is the one who's
always concerned about debt because they
had
she had debt always afraid of what can
go wrong
and so not saying that you should try to
smother frannie
or ignore franny but rather acknowledge
hey franny i hear you
i do have my debt pay off plan but
i've also decided i'm not going to wait
and spend nothing
while i'm paying this debt off i'm going
to be reasonable and have a balance
another pattern is that people create a
story for themselves
and then they live it but this story can
often be popped like a balloon
with just a few questions so somebody
will say something like well i'm
he's good with money i'm not and i'll go
is that true and then she will go oh
yeah yeah
i go hey out of curiosity have you read
my book
no do you think if you were to read this
book that you might be able to get
pretty decent with money and that's a
beautiful moment
because suddenly that person realizes
that story they've been telling
themselves
may not be true i mentioned that people
minimize the problem
you know they'll say this is a 4 out of
10 but a 4 out of 10
left alone in a couple especially when
there's kids and a mortgage involved
turns into a 9 out of 10 so whether it's
emptying the dishwasher
or spending on starbucks this one really
surprised me which is
stress is not correlated to the amount
of
debt stress is not correlated to the
amount of debt
so there was a couple that had about six
hundred thousand dollars of
debt educational debt they were
two of the most capable calm people i've
met
like they were awesome they have this
huge amount of debt
but they had a plan they were aligned
and they were
clearly in love the way that they were
talking about taking care of each other
that really showed that the amount is
not necessarily correlated to the stress
and finally people often don't treat
finances
in their relationship like a business
and they let it
they think that it's weird to have an
agenda or a plan
as i mentioned there's nothing weird
about it at all i've always been a fan
of just doing things that might seem
weird but if they work for you they work
for you
and so for any couple listening hey if
you have some weird thing you want to do
but it works for the two of you
fantastic don't let anybody including me
tell you not to do it
just focus on what where you want to get
to together with your partner
do you have any other recommendations
for
people listening who want to further
explore sort of developing the skill
of financial comfort right which i do
think is a skill
i think it's a it has many different
component parts
we've covered a decent amount already
are there any other
recommendations you might have resources
that you think would help
people develop a higher degree of
comfort having these conversations right
there you know they're books like
crucial conversations or crucial
confrontations i think is
the follow-up to it that can help with
these types of things but any any other
thoughts whether they be exercises
resources
yeah anything else i'll give you two one
is i'm a big fan of the gottman
institute
and um my wife and i took a class there
for an entire weekend and
it was very time consuming and energy
consuming
but it was really worth it just to put a
stake in the ground that says our
relationship is important to us
we're setting time aside for this so
that's one
and two is i often ask couples to write
down
what kind of couple they want to be
what do they want people to think of
them
and we all know this we all have couple
friends where when we think about them
you know a few words come to mind
and i ask them oftentimes they'll say
something like they're generous
they're fun and then after they've
written down this
typically very glowing document of what
they want to be known as
i ask them how do you reconcile that
with the conversation we've been having
about spending money at target
or the pizza place and it becomes very
clear that there's
a discontinuity that's okay now we say
how can we rewrite
our actions to match up if you claim you
want to be generous
can we just tip an extra 15
and just start being known as generous
because we are generous
and suddenly they realize oh my gosh i
created this thing but i haven't been
living up to it and it only takes a tiny
switch
to completely change that yeah yeah the
tipping example is a great one right
it's like look if the bill
even if the bill is small if you just
make the commitment to like always tip
five bucks it's incredible how far that
will
go right like if you buy like a coffee
and
you tip five bucks like you just made
someone's day and it's
it really can change how you think about
the positive power of money bingo it's
such a
it's such a small thing i'm so glad we
talk about that my wife and i
added that to our line item of expenses
the same as
gifts charity we added tipping and we
added a number that was
big enough that we have to go out of our
way
to tip larger like it actually is
pulling us
towards tipping more not just reflecting
what we normally tip
and the same as you we recognize that
a 20 tip to somebody else is
incredibly meaningful incredibly
and we would rather just work harder and
earn more and be able to
easily do that and so you know when we
talk about being generous and charitable
and adventurous this is what money can
do for you and can do for the people
around you
just as a quick personal note and i've
i've
mentioned this before which usually i
hate when people say that on any podcast
because i'm like well i don't want to be
the
johnny come lately getting this for the
20th time but it just goes to show the
power of the experience
i have mentioned probably 15 times on
this podcast
that at some point when i was
14 or 15 working as a busboy
billy joel would come into this
restaurant where i worked
and he would have a coffee read a
newspaper
and he would tip 20 bucks for his coffee
and that
blew my mind i mean like 20 bucks was a
big
deal to me and
i remember that being and he also took
time to chat i
worked up the courage one shift i
haven't told this part over like
two hours because he would take his time
to walk up and ask him how he met
christy brinkley because they were
together at the time
and that that was that was incredible
for those who don't know
incredible power couple i mean and i
wanted to ask him so i worked up the
courage and he turned to me and he
talked to me for a few minutes
and you know to this day
i remember that experience so vividly
remember what i was wearing i remember
the table he was sitting at i remember
all of it i remember which side of the
table
and in that moment i remember thinking
wow
one day if i could just be so
rich and successful that i could tip
twenty dollars for coffee that is the
craziest thing i've ever seen in my life
right so you think about the effect that
had on me right
this this this really small thing which
i'm i'm sure
you know he's done a hundred times so he
would have no memory of it but this like
chance encounter
small thing just really can make an
impact it's huge so i'm glad you
mentioned tempi
that's awesome and now for everyone to
be able to hear all
the millions of people listening to this
to be able to hear that
yeah you can tip 10 20
100 nobody's stopping you from tipping
more
and many of us find it easier
to tip or to spend money on others but
you can also do the same for yourself
and there's no shame in spending
extravagantly on the things you love
that is the classic way to create your
rich life here here and
if people go to 10. blog fort slash
prenup
which will be created by the time this
airs and people listen to our previous
conversation we talk about the levers
right then 10xing on very specific
things and
how you can think through that but for
this episode we're coming to a close
ramit sethi twitter instagram ramit
r-a-m-i-t
his new podcast i will teach you to be
rich
by ramit seti you can find it wherever
fine podcasts are served and
you can find it also at iwt.com forward
slash podcast
i'm glad better late than never you're
finally
in the audio game and i've been looking
forward
to you entering the fray so i have no
doubt that it will be
outstanding and encourage people to
check it out is there anything else you
would like to
share any closing comments requests of
people who are listening
anything you'd like to point folks to
before we come to a close
yeah i would love to hear from all your
listeners tim whether they want to do it
through
twitter instagram dms whatever
i'd love to hear how your first
conversation goes with your partner
this is a real beautiful crux of a
moment you get to start
this conversation it will last you years
and years and it's
you and your partner creating your rich
life together so let me know how it goes
i would be so curious to hear from you
and if you are not in a couple
you could i'm going to volunteer you or
me to also get feedback because i know
you have means for
contending with this for people who test
the 100
challenge yeah love that in the next 48
hours after hearing this
then i will get i'll get the highlights
and the low lights via via
screenshots and text messages from
mermaid
and uh i'm gonna go order that
cashmere onesie for you on amazon
and then you can you can wear the infant
swaddling cloth on your head
you might be able to fashion that into
something maybe a kerchief for your suit
and look forward to hanging again soon
man yeah i can't wait to see you in
person
yeah it'll be really fun to see you in
person and
any anything else you would like to add
do you feel complete
i do feel complete and i want to thank
you for the warm welcome to
podcasting land you have been a
fantastic mentor and you know you've
just been a good friend and been patient
as i
spent the last seven years trying to
find the concept that i was really
excited about but
now that i've found it it feels right
and i'm very very excited about it
yeah i'm excited for you i'm excited for
your listeners as well i will teach you
to be rich
bye ramit sethi check it out iwt.com
podcast or you can just search ramit
seti on the interwebs and podcast and
i'm sure it'll come
right up ramit thank you as always for
hanging great to see you thanks tim
and to everybody listening we'll also
have links to everything we discussed
in the show notes as per usual
at tim dot blog forward slash podcast
and
until next time thank you for tuning in
you